which is by the way a good thing
no reason what the [ __ ]
can you imagine sitting through a whole
seminar of something else and at the end
that's the thesis thank you guys for
coming now you all know
[Music]
welcome back to care for boys we are
indeed very careful boys I'm only
bringing this up because I have this
prompt this is my personal prompt for
once yeah Anthony I just want a [ __ ]
answer and and I think that maybe you're
the only person who can actually answer
this what is with chicks and your need
to cover everything with [ __ ] pillows
like what's actually going on I pick you
up I second this what do you mean cover
everything every goddamn thing you
[ __ ] got a bench you got like a
[ __ ] bed you got a [ __ ] couch you
got you got a [ __ ] little little sofa
little Nook little Chase Lounge oh
you're talking about like decorative
pillows like everything
the [ __ ] yeah it's funny because I
actually agree with this I agree how
many pillows you have in your house
first and foremost
only the necessary ones wow which is
what 34. yeah 34 34. I have four pillows
on my bed because that has four heads is
[Laughter]
okay so we got four pillows on the bed
okay we got four pillows right one for
my head one for me to like wrap my leg
around one for my back you know to feel
safe and then the third one sorry the
fourth one is just I mean just for
[ __ ]
my [ __ ] pillow that one well that one's
special that one well it's sad and then
the couch only has two okay
how many
sectionals yeah it's like a like a eight
to nine person couch a nine person couch
with only two pillows I'm impressed
listen but you're asking again you're
asking the wrong person because can you
teach women like what can you do
something about this that'll be a
segment so my woman not to buy
decorative pillows so my wife
do you have a problem
there's there's just a serious thing
going on in my marriage just speak about
it just be happy I'm just gonna be
completely honest my marriage on the
[ __ ] rocks right now okay I'm looking
for a way out you know it's your problem
right because she's the one who's making
bucks right now like you're [ __ ] up
you sure you want a way out you're
spending money she's making look at your
outfit Bro Look at like three thousand
dollars per track suit yeah tell me
about it no so like my wife
like so she's like
oh so you're not gonna make the bed
today and I'm like oh well you know
making the bed means I gotta put 60
[ __ ] seven pillows like in in an
arrangement you know like like what the
[ __ ] is with that like I didn't buy
first of all even one pillow I don't
even want one of these pillows I just
want the one that's for my head that's
it but but these [ __ ] love
covering the whole [ __ ] bed all the
way to the edge of the bed so there's
nothing and it has to be matching they
have to have the right pattern I have a
California king that's a lot of pillows
you gotta put okay so wait a different
perspective if you
went to a woman's house and she didn't
have that situation would you think
differently of her would you be like why
why aren't you so much
I'd probably say will you marry me
I probably get on one knee and I have
[ __ ] tears for my [ __ ] eyes you're
like when can I move in because because
men don't give a [ __ ] about that they're
telling you about like the Aesthetics
you're goddamn right it's practical and
that's it no no I care about Aesthetics
because I'm trying to get like a
different perspective to me practicality
and Aesthetics aren't like mutually
exclusive it shouldn't take 28 minutes
to make a bet I agree I agree with that
yeah like uh when I have
whenever some [ __ ] how many pillows
do you want on your bed let me tell you
let me tell you what I have okay let's
set the stage I don't even have a king I
got a queen it's La yes Queen and we
thank you yes Queen me too and we got
like eight pillows that's a lot for a
queen a lot that's I need one wow Four's
already like eight is a lot this is my
literally I'm just so used to it I've
complained about it for like are they
yours no well they'll say Anthony hours
[Laughter]
you guys have different sizes right it's
like the the big ones in the back
it's as if it's like you're walking into
a [ __ ] Ikea but nobody else is
shopping right and every [ __ ] night I
before I go to bed it's it's nonchalant
it's routine there's no emotion I go to
my bed I take pills I throw it on to the
[ __ ] floor on the floor
they're passionate about it no trays no
trays with candles and [ __ ]
decorative books she really has that on
the bed at all God damn right and I hate
my [ __ ] [ __ ] on it in the middle of
night and I'm like oh God
that's on the California King what the
[ __ ] and there's no light sources in the
room my eyes already suck ass during the
day by the way try to go to the restroom
tripping on all these pillows yeah so at
night I'm hitting my [ __ ] I hit my
[ __ ] on her she buys a stupid [ __ ]
gold trade gets it on I don't know some
stupid websites overpriced as hell like
Neiman Marcus or some [ __ ] right but we
have a tray on the bed what does the
tray do it doesn't hold cables what
candles that you don't like so like this
is a a new candle like basically in the
plastic and also there's like four books
like architectural design nobody read it
books like like women through the 19
[ __ ] 30s for the 50s nobody ever read
it ever I know what you're talking about
all the women
what the [ __ ] is that it's just a photo
book who the [ __ ] knows right but but
it's aesthetically pleasing yeah right
yeah
exactly yeah right it's all on my stupid
tray on the [ __ ] foot of my bed but
for her doesn't matter because she could
stretch out oh like this take a big good
morning and like she'll never ever even
touch the tray but me just getting into
bed God damn it oh my [ __ ] God my
[ __ ] oh my God I broke a bone welcome to
my life one of my marriage on the
[ __ ] world
[Laughter]
it's on the rocks
listen decorative pillows is destroying
lives people don't even know about
nobody talks about it what do you think
would happen when you normalize it and
she found her bed
empty like there's only maybe two
pillows what if you just ended up
throwing everything I guess we got
rocked I'll tell you exactly what
happened
they took only the pillow this [ __ ]
should go to [ __ ] Target a World
Market or some [ __ ] and buy it
yeah
do not [ __ ] with cos Plus World Market
that plays the [ __ ]
by the way I am practical I go I go to
the airport with Nikki I'm carrying all
our bags it's four bags right and Mickey
can't even handle two cops Plus World
Market this [ __ ] has 17 cards she's
like [ __ ] dragging them all
[ __ ] somehow she finds a strike to
take every single card she's got like 17
cards in the daisy chain all the way
through the whole [ __ ] thing
spending 1400 on pillows and stupid
[ __ ] trays and [ __ ]
that's that poker money they find the
strength is the source of this problem
do you think is there some kind of
aggressive marketing campaign towards
women that makes them want more pillows
but I need you to I need it
save his marriage save his marriage you
guys gotta get a new guest because I'm
not helping clean you're here for
answers that we don't have you're
bringing in a female that has a
completely different respective operates
much differently like don't hear and he
gives us answers we don't need you're
here and I don't give you any answer do
you have anything that is more than the
amount I gave you an answer I said take
the pillows when she's gone and toss
them out no she'll know it's me just
keep donating them it's fine I'm the one
who [ __ ] about it I'm the one who's
smiling I'm like let's go wrong this is
what you're gonna do you're gonna do
like a Conway a Kanye West strategy
you're gonna not complain about it for
at least like two weeks okay don't
complain about it for two weeks good
luck bring in like a friend who comes
over like every other day and they
complain about the goddamn pillows and
then just pin it on them yes and then
that's when you make your move Bart
please will you do it no dude you can't
get part get find out who she idolizes
in life and make friends with them have
them become a poker player yeah like a
poker champ have him walk in the first
thing he says is what the [ __ ] are all
these pillows right if you want to make
it to the big leagues you get rid of
these [ __ ] pillows you want to get
your face it's it's funny
she might get more pillows after that
she might get more that's the fear just
just gets you know take them all in for
crocheting and have say White lives
matter on each of them
you should ask her if she wants to be in
a relationship with you or the pillows
give her a dilemma oh don't do that that
could end badly your ass is outside
quick I'm too insecure about the answer
it'll make you get pillows for the pool
right all right oh yeah we might as well
have pillows in the pool bro we might as
well have pills in the pool because
there's so many goddamn floaties out
there just air dry them she puts a lot
of floaties so many [ __ ] floaties
does she use the pool a lot yeah oh well
that's nice but not the great pool
floaties are for girls exclusively yeah
pretty much I'll never be caught dead
one because you know why people would
say that that's weird
very clean with your outfit you look
like you have floaties on Deck thank you
yeah I do but they're not mine if I were
to do a music video for you it would be
in a pool he's got a Margaritaville you
know I do have a Margaritaville thank
you very much hey thanks for listening I
know you do you look like Margaritaville
right now you do you look like
Margaritaville and Fat Tuesday's collab
how it so so how are you how do your
chicks
affect your lives through your home
usually pillows in the bed like we have
the [ __ ] up thing you have the same
problem does she make you adhere to the
rules she's like why aren't you making
the bed like what's funny do you even
love me she doesn't she doesn't really
give me [ __ ] for making the bed for not
making the bed sometimes I do it but
then other times it's like do you guys
got rules though kind of very loose
rules is your marriage on the Rocks over
it no not yet soon to be probably
because you got me fired up and I'm
gonna go home and I'm gonna you guys say
all your ideas stand up for men stand up
fermentation the pillows out the window
yeah I'm gonna do it but we have don't
be soft like Anthony
in our bed we have like 10 pounds how
did you add the [ __ ] effeminate voice
so quickly that's what I heard when he
said that kind of [ __ ] basically he's
saying is you like the pillows oh yeah
do you like the pillows and do you make
the bed every day I love my lady
okay do you like the pillows though oh
my God
he did it that was good
come on do you like the [ __ ] pillows
that you [ __ ] throw away every day
you put it back on it's truth be told I
complained about him a lot and then she
[ __ ] argued me all the time and I
realized she [ __ ] loves them so now I
just don't say [ __ ] did she ever give
you like an actual answer why like that
made sense other than just I like she's
never had logic that's why I love her
you know what's weird is I have I have a
lot of pillows only on the couch and I
realize that it's it's a leftover
mentality from when I was in high school
and I used to have friends sleepover all
the time so they would always want a
pillow and an extra blanket I have extra
pillows and blankets all the time even
though I have no stuff that's different
I have extra pillows and I have extra
blanks all the time and they're in like
a little [ __ ] baskets for friends
it's literally a basket for that and
they're like crash yeah there have been
times where there's like from one move
to the next transition here discount
here at Cost Plus whatever the [ __ ]
happened where I needed to buy three get
one free type nonsense those are good
and suddenly there's all these pillows
here and I'm I'm literally I've told
I've told her too I'm like this pillow
doesn't even match with everything going
on and then she has to finally be like
okay oh you gaslighter yeah you're a
gaslighter dude that's how you do it
that's what no I got [ __ ] we don't
have the style sense to be able to give
a suggestion like that yeah dude that's
true so I have a style system
that's not fair that's manipulative
that's [ __ ] you yeah
oh I should I guess I should put a wound
necklace in all these pillows huh
I'm like how do I answer that
Steven media is like I guess I gotta
order 14 woo necklaces I should check
out yeah maybe she's being literal
doesn't sound sarcastic okay here's his
semi hot take all right go for it I'm
totally sure maybe some people might get
upset at me for this
I'll be vulnerable I'm gonna be honest
okay put some tom yum soup in this
conversation so me and my lady been
together for
all right and uh she let me just put it
this way she just started working after
her uh post graduate career this year
this is her first year working like full
full time yeah nice which means and
she's always had side jobs odd jobs you
know ran things on the side so she
always kind of like took care of herself
a little bit but at the end of the day
we've also been living together for like
nearly six plus years and realistically
I've I've always been the one to just
kind of financially take care of stuff
right now she's she's nursing right
nervous and now now I'm totally reliable
yeah she's an OT it's a doctor of OT so
it's great very good it's secure it's
great for the dog
you know what I'm talking about it's
great for that what's OT stand for uh
occupational therapist point is right
before when I was uh The Breadwinner if
you will for whatever people use that
term yeah wow um whoa the concept of
like how things happen in the home I did
feel in titled to a little bit more of
the concept of equity even though I was
always a little bit of a pushover at the
end of the day when it comes to my lady
anyway with the house it's like she
wants something like we'll [ __ ] try
to logic through it if there's no logic
there it's like [ __ ] it you really like
it I don't actually care but I will say
since this year since inflation since
the rent went up on our place since she
started making money since we came into
a new negotiation where she like pays
her way and you know like plays her part
a lot more sounds very dangerous a
little bit can't give them a choice dude
however it has subconsciously and
psychologically put me at a completely
different place and at ease one at ease
yeah you're no longer a king of the
castle dude I thought she was like every
time she was talking to just bring
[ __ ] apple boxes standing on them so
she can [ __ ] talk down to you like I
am the breadwinner Anthony that's what
she does first of all Gio doesn't even
stand on apple boxes how did you get
that creative ideas no [ __ ] mean to
stand on top apple boxes so she can stop
talking about Nina like that
is small she's she is small point is
point is I now
in some whatever normal concept of
probably human existence you say yes
mommy I'm just way less yeah way less
you know if she wants to do something
I'm I'm more roommate you know what I
mean yeah you know when you're a little
bit more roommate less like like we're
one in the same relationship things need
to have a household whatever the [ __ ]
I'm the man of the house it's not really
about that as much now it's I'm more
roommate about stuff now because she
like you know pays and plays her part a
little bit more than before and our
relationship's more Mutual in that way
if she like wants something I feel less
of a vote to like deny it or anything
like that not saying I did before but
just like a lot more like
yes okay or like I'm like hey let me let
me do more around the house so I can
like earn my place because it's just
relative to literally the percentage of
like pay structure
um because I don't know maybe there was
this uh understanding when I was a
younger person especially in the Asian
household I was like you know as a guy
I'm just gonna financially take care of
whatever that's just what I got to do
you don't live with me Anthony
yes you can take care of me man how does
this help Steve with the pillow thing I
just think you now that she makes more
money than you because she definitely
makes more money than you I just think
you need to [ __ ] listen to her yeah
Let It Go that's what I'm saying I just
feel like you should just shut the [ __ ]
up whoa what if my answer is I don't
take advice from stupid dancers
oh he's about to start wheezing why are
you laughing you're a [ __ ] dancing
because I think it's funny that he
listened quietly the whole time
he was so like if you if you guys go
back and look at his face he's like
and then just goes I don't take advice
from dancers
no what actually Nikki's a Dancer by the
way
um a strip dancer on my lap maybe let's
go
um but but it's on the it's on the Rocks
it's on the Rocks because the pillows
that's what I'm saying that's all I'm
saying you don't want to save it up all
right we'll see you guys I think my idea
she's the breadwinner now that's all I'm
saying is she's the breadwinner now we
all know that maybe you should be okay
with her pillows and her [ __ ] trays
and her [ __ ] architectural digest in
1930s women what's some [ __ ] that Nikki
gets mad at you about equally around the
house
he doesn't know how to [ __ ] take out
the trash at their house I know this I
heard it on a phone conversation while I
was there but when we first came over he
was taking out the trash yeah yeah along
with all the noodles that he didn't want
can Japan noodles uh TM
did you just trade more yeah not just
not not the spicy ones because it didn't
exist yet because they couldn't figure
it out yet just to be just to be clear
this little said Tia they didn't know
how to make the noodles spicy yet that
took a long time
just to be clear the focus of the issue
here is Steve and his ability or
inability to listen to his wife and love
her pillow crates not the noodles uh no
the focus of this is why dancers suck
and they're gay
[Laughter]
which is by the way
which is by the way a good thing it's
actually a really good thing
no reason so just in case
if you suppose that's why you're wrong
and it's a good thing
can you imagine sitting through a whole
seminar of something else and at the end
that's the thesis thank you guys for
coming now you all know wait what the
moral I don't I actually don't remember
the trash thing because the trash has
been like I've been bank shot in that
[ __ ] non-stop what was the traffic
actually do you remember I just remember
that she was like can you go take out
the trash you're like sure I'm gonna go
take out the trash you go out and take
out the trash four or five minutes later
you call her while I'm sitting there
with her on the couch you're like I
can't [ __ ] find this afternoon she's
like the trash cans right the [ __ ]
outside you just go this way how come
you can't [ __ ] take a shot it was a
new house and you just started yelling
at each other on the phone the bins so
it was actually for my neighbor because
I actually it was my neighbor's out of
town I was actually trying to help my
neighbor out yeah I couldn't find theirs
and so I thought that changes the
dynamic I thought that maybe the
neighbor told me but I didn't know but
then like yeah but Nikki knew I do like
that yeah I just I was like sitting in a
very [ __ ] wholesome conversation I
was like oh Steve's taking all the trash
I'm sitting here on the couch in Nikki's
house with Nikki maybe I should like use
this moment to warm up get to know her a
little bit like things are nice I'm like
yo how's she getting a poker ball boss
she's like oh next you know a [ __ ]
phone call comes in and they're just
cussing each other out loud as [ __ ] yeah
yeah he's on speakerphone they're just
like [ __ ] you [ __ ] you and I'm sitting
there I'm like people who so that's the
best part
as much as we're on the Rocks do you
guys play it up he's all saving himself
right as much from On The Rocks no that
is like our favorite thing to do like
like I can't even tell you the names
that she calls me all day it's your
guy's thing though yeah I have a
question what do you have when you have
like a new person in the house like
Anthony Lee do you guys play it up a
little we do yeah
I just want to make it feel more Awkward
no we actually do yeah I'm not [ __ ]
Prime Suspect right I'm like an Asian
boy who like probably hasn't seen
domestic violence as much as I probably
need to and it wasn't trash it was male
it was it was male because because like
I didn't know where our mailbox is oh it
was mail that's what it was but I I
didn't know where the mailbox were for
our neighbor because I was supposed to
pick up our neighbor's mail and so like
I I like went to our mailbox and I tried
their stupid key and I was like that
doesn't [ __ ] work and then Nikki's
like it works you [ __ ] idiot and like
she's like tell me all kinds of [ __ ] it
was great and then and then like I go to
the other mailbox that I could see in
line of sight and like that one didn't
work and so I'm like well definitely
this [ __ ] is [ __ ] I think he's a
[ __ ] idiot and then I call her I'm
like you stupid [ __ ] [ __ ] like this
[ __ ] doesn't it's not there you stupid
[ __ ] [ __ ] it's like you stupid
[ __ ] and then she called me a monster
stuff and then and I'm sitting there on
the couch like yeah white people yeah
well is Nikki that white
that part of her seems white she was
raised white wasn't she I mean it's more
like a white teenager or a biscuit fan
yeah she wasn't kind of
using like white vocabulary he was
playing to your culture she's she's yeah
yeah Nikki Nikki by the way is not white
at all
um but it's pretty funny but yeah no but
no uh so then I found our neighbor I
found our neighbors our neighbor's
mailbox and now all is well until the
pillow thing now we're on the Rock
full circle back on the Rock so we don't
have a solution for you hey sorry to
hear that man thanks guys I like your
guys's teamwork that's very sweet
thank you
[Music]